صراصير مشويه او مسلوقه او ربما جراد مشوي
كلها اطباق شائعه في دوله لاوس حيث يستمتع
السكان باكل انواع مختلفه من الحشرات
اللذيذه على حد وصفهم
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده منه
عالم غريب
تقع لاوس في جنوب شرق اسيا الى الشمال
الشرقي من تايلاند يسكنها نحو سبعه ملايين
ونصف المليون نسمه
95% من السكان هنا يتناولون هذه الحشرات
الصغيره الغريبه ويفضلون تقديمها كمقبلات
[موسيقى]
السكان هنا يتناولون الحشرات بوصفات
تحضيريه مختلفه واحيانا
يلتهمونها حيه في الاسواق يمكنك الحصول
على جميع انواع الحشرات البريه والتي تمت
تربيتها في مزارع مخصصه لها والغريب انها
تباع بمبالغ مرتفعه وليست رخيصه الثمن كما
يعتقد البعض
انتاج الحشرات في لاوس يعتمد بشكل اساسي
على الانتاج المنزلي هنا سيده تدعى
وتقوم بتربيه الصراصير في الفناء الخلفي
لمنزلها هذا النوع من الصراصير هو الانسب
لتكاثر ومن اكثر الانواع ربحيه وفي غضون
اربعين يوما تصبح بيضه الصراصير حشره
ناضجه وجاهزه لسيوان
خبره اهل لاوس في تربيه الحشرات المجهزه
للاكل احالتهم لتقديم المشوره لرجال
الاعمال الاوروبيين الراغبين في الدخول في
تجاره الحشرات ونقل هذه الوجبات الى
بلادهم
[موسيقى]
تناول الحشرات اسلوب غذائي متبع في العديد
من الدول ليس في لاوس وحدها
5 مثلا هناك توجه لبعض السكان لتصبح
الديدان بديلا صحيا للحوم حسب ما يعتقدون
اكشن
في وقت يواجه فيه العالم تحديات كبيره
فيما يتعلق بالامن الغذائي يعتقد عشاق
الحشرات والديدان ان الاعتماد على هذه
الكائنات الصغيره سيكون الحل الامثل في
المستقبل
لمواجهه شبح الجوع
تعتقدون اننا سنلجا الى تناولها يوما ما